[Music]
and mughals mughals scam news did I say
that muggle scam is that some heavy
putter okay got it
it is a Harry Potter reference awesome
submitted by stranger danger Harry
Potter fans are angry over a fifty
dollar scam event
well hapa of all the fan bases to get
scammed other than anime this is my
second favorite I mean my fifty dollars
is still like that's not that my
favorite video for a while was the
Dumbledore dies and yeah they go no
Snape kills Dumbledore no tell me so
there was a guy that read the book and
then he what he skimmed yeah well he
skimmed then he got the ending and then
there was a huge line for the kids to
get the Harry Potter book and then he
drove by and he said Dumbledore dies
Dumbledore dies no he says rape kills
Dumbledore yeah and everyone's like
because he's driving the can do [ __ ]
yeah yeah but that was like why watch it
don't add your MOT your monster yeah
alright so this event here it was
organized by a real company called lol
event group that sounds like a troll
group yep so this is what the events
description said join our wizard
inspired adults-only festival as
montreal turns into a world of magical
wonder and retold yourself with
specialty themed of alcoholic adult
drinks like boozy butterbeer Polyjuice
potion unicorn blood hair of the
multi-headed dog and more sample themed
bites like luna loves pudding ron family
sweater cookies oh Jesus cakes and
butterscotch beer popcorn visit
cobblestone Ellie and to pick your wand
or have it choose you and take photos
with real-life characters there will be
lots of great
magical photo opportunities live music
from DJ Dobbs and the Porter putt Porter
party band prized trivia cornhole snitch
toss and much more costumes are of
course encouraged your ticket includes a
free themed alcoholic drink of your
choice samples of wizard themed treats
unlimited access to photo opportunities
games prize trivia live music debauchery
and mischief anything that says
debauchery and draped I was into that
part but everything else was off it
sounds like a wizard
orgy it sounds like we're going
I was listening like ooh nice drinks
already got me ready to go yeah with the
price of admission we get a free drink
it makes me want to go there and kick
everyone's ass Thank You Bart thank you
I actually just want to go there and go
like this because you're hitting
everyone you're heading they deserve it
everyone every single one no let me
drink my butter beer and stupid ones
sighs you're saying it wrong it's maybe
Oh saw
I'll get Harry Potter fans that one
thing butter beer is good it's so good I
went to Universal Studios and went
through the Harry Potter portion of it
and I'm not even a huge Harry Potter fan
but for 50 bucks
[ __ ] I'm buying that ticket we're going
what's butter beer tastes like it's like
advanced cream soda it's so good yeah
and then you go in and it's really
themed
and I'm butterscotch flavor um I have to
go
that sounds good just for the butter
beer mm-hmm and then you go into the
restaurants and then it's all themed
like if you're into that it's dope I'm
into imagination yes dope and if you're
not you're like what is that people you
know what I'm like one foot in not in
one foot in yes because I fix a huge fan
so when I went like we got to see it
when we're in Osaka I was like I really
feel like I'm I'm in our world
all Japanese that's pretty funny what's
the output no part is the fact that I
didn't read any of the books but did you
watch the movies because of Isaac and I
really like fully like was I really
watching the movie I was just like oh
it's on let me like okay we're watching
the movie I'll be on my phone sometimes
a little kind of watch it I'm not like
in it to be like I know every character
every plotline like I'm not and all on
my nerd [ __ ] I went to Star Wars land
cuz I thought I liked Star Wars but I
thought Star Wars land stuff but I was
expecting to like it okay because they
created in yeah man right yeah it's just
a [ __ ] Star Wars shopping mall good
it was I know I wish it was site it was
sick but instead they just made a
[ __ ] mall and they don't even have
like original trilogy [ __ ] it's just all
the new [ __ ] which is well where was
that now if you're into it that [ __ ]
must piss you off
it's [ __ ] well no it's like this
right so you go there and you're like
wait everyone's taking pictures in front
of the one thing that's in the actual
movie is the [ __ ] Millennium Falcon
everything else nobody gives a [ __ ]
about because they've never seen it
before it's like hey let's invent a
Harry Potter theme park but have nothing
from Harry Potter and it's from a
different world in the same universe as
Harry Potter I was like who gives a [ __ ]
cuz I don't know anything about like
really cool so the experience of it was
more of what you were into because I
don't know anything about it so I
thought this was all pieces from the
movies I get from the world hi who
r2d2 he's he's he's there but he have to
pay $30 walking around alone Game of
Thrones world double equals the new
stormtroopers it's not the old ones man
there's a difference
yeah there is actually the old ones are
the ICONic there is there is a big
difference oh my bad dude different
Lorien I haven't seen yet notice okay
okay so anyway wait what the [ __ ] is
that I don't know what that is
baby Yoda you watching [ __ ] spoiler
everywhere there's memes all over I just
Dumbledore's memes everywhere I need the
nobody not sure
so back to this of a Harry Potter themed
thing so when they arrived at the
location
the guests were greeted by a dry erase
board that said magic this way well I
can't wait to hear what they really bad
and then they were saying that the
drinks instead of the boozy butter beer
Polyjuice potion and hair of the
multi-headed dog
they just got regular ass cocktails
nothing special about it well so the
cocktails y'all are drinking our regular
ass cocktails that you're paid for by
bar true but like they were really like
not even nice will spring us some photos
in a second maybe like a cool glass yeah
so then all that food that they
mentioned like noonas love pudding and
Ron's family sweater cookie jello you
weren't there either I mean they just
weren't there but instead there were
several aluminum trees filled with
lukewarm supermarket appetizers family
style that we're on toothpicks more than
toothpicks it's like the veggie plate
welcome yonas cocktail wienies I wish I
could have seen everyone's face the
little weenies the little sausages and
then this is their uh their cauldron
Ellie
master troll master oh yeah she didn't
dress up right look at her she were like
this is the decor that's like when you
have no budget that's people booing it
in person if you don't even get a
sticker on it this is worse than a high
school dance this is the [ __ ] food
patience sorry what was that [ __ ]
event that all the models we're
promoting and [ __ ] that fire fest yeah
that's what this is right they're
calling it the fire faith of the mobile
world at least you're not in another
your Alicia not on some Island right no
sister warms you can you can leave here
in ways that fire [ __ ] like this like
I'm wooden chopsticks and stuff they
were meant so you can put glitter on
them and decorate them and make your
with your one chopsticks legends my ass
was like you can't eat with glitter
chopsticks you'll eat the glitter you're
not supposed to that's good point so be
more pissed there's 50 bucks we bad
like this is not even an activity for
children like it was bad bad 50 bucks
I'd grab that laptop and say thank you
and walk away for 50 bucks I'm taking
all the alcohol way yeah legs words for
50 bucks that's two drinks in San
Francisco so take the drain and and
check how is that how is the bar scene
in San Francisco
like $15 a drink god they're like 12
beers like seven I just left the club
that I was working at I mean it's cool
if you like it and it could be really
dope but San Francisco is made for
people with money and if you go out you
better have money if not you're the free
before 11:00 crowd and we all know it's
the whole city full of nerds so we all
know that you bought the blue drink
because it has the most in it and you're
probably gonna pass out down the street
and most people commute right because
they don't even live there yeah I mean
to living to live in San Francisco yeah
I was commuting from like
an hour away to go work in the city yeah
I was commuting from like over an hour
away commuting is that like taking the
train or you drive I mean most people
that work in like San Francisco don't
live in San Francisco and if you do
you're cashing out like real bread so if
you can go out and pay $15 for a drink
you're straight but I didn't realize how
expensive [ __ ] was until I stopped
working there and had to buy my own
drink cuz I didn't want to do to buy it
for me and I was like wow this [ __ ] is
wack
we're gonna drink at home because I'm
secretly poor and I can't hang out and I
don't wanna have to flirt with you we're
pre-gaming and we're never leaving I
mean if I pregame I'm more likely to go
out and then next thing you know you
don't realize how faded you are cuz you
have one drink of it you're like I get
home how do ya know
that's yeah you have a good friend I did
that to a friend of Mines party recently
the river supposed to have a Christmas
party how important they do it every
year
I [ __ ] love these people it's always
fun but they told me the day of they're
like we just didn't have the energy we
want a bar crawl the night and said I'm
like [ __ ] bar Chloe I'm over 30 in that
bar calling it stuff and that's a couple
hundred dollars what sucks I hate it
trash so then I showed up at the party
and I just worked everyone in the room
individually I'm a no boy no bar girl no
boy no more and then eventually was like
hey let's borrow everyone's like we're
good let's just stay here and then and
it was probably wow a much better way
better was perfect it was exactly what
we had to call the producer but back to
this [ __ ] Harry Potter party right
thank you
so people that attended this event they
ended up creating their own Facebook
page that was called cheated by lol
event group because these people were
not getting refunds
oh no bucks is a lot for that garbage if
I paid five bucks to get in I would have
been fine with it right I think they
could have gotten away with it if I have
to pay anything in advance and I don't
like it I'm asking for a refund well is
it like $50 in free drinks well they
said that it was a drink included oh wow
but still I want my [ __ ] 25 dollars
back yeah fifty bucks
this man in Montreal these boxes like
you're at a Miami Dolphins game you're
staying in the president's suite [ __ ]
the Dolphins again
[Music]
[Music]